guys I'm sorry this took a little bit
longer than usual but I've been down
with a nasty cold and I have just
started to get my voice back so let's
talk about my most anticipated films of
2015 which is a crazy year filled with
hopefully amazing awesome entertainment
now I'm not gonna cover every humungous
thing I'm just gonna talk about some of
the major ones I'm looking forward to it
I'm not gonna talk about them for too
long otherwise I'm gonna be sitting here
for an hour but first off Jupiter
ascending the Wachowski is next film
that was pushed back I'm very curious
about this movie and I'm always curious
to see what they've done but I haven't
really loved a movie they've done since
the matrix in all honesty next on my
list is a little independent horror film
called it follows now I'm not gonna tell
you the plot of this movie just in case
you don't know the plot of the movie
because the plot of the movie is pretty
incredible Lost River is Ryan Gosling's
directorial debut now for that reason
I'm curious to see what he's done I'm
not saying it's gonna be great I don't
even know it could be really terrible
but from what I've heard from the Cannes
Film Festival everyone hated it but
can't Film Festival hates everything and
then for a while it wasn't getting a
theatrical release and going straight to
VOD and now it is gonna be in a few
theaters well also being in VOD in April
I'm looking forward to seeing what he
did behind the camera Furious 7 I'm
looking forward to simply because the
last two Fast and Furious movies have
been a lot of fun and I'm really curious
to see how they assembled this movie not
just from James Juan's perspective as a
director of action but how they handle
the whole Paul Walker situation that's
really what I'm curious to see how they
do and if they can pull it off I'm
really hoping this movie's successful
because they went through a lot of
problems in the production obviously and
I'm pulling for this movie there's this
little movie coming out called Avengers
age of Ultron I'm not sure if too many
people have heard about this one I know
it's from a small studio called Marvel
and it features a lot of comic-book
characters that maybe are not entirely
known but I have a feeling it could be
pretty good and it's directed by this
guy named Joss Whedon I don't really
know if he's ever done anything in the
past but um I'm hoping it's good Mad Max
fury road looks pretty insane if you've
seen any of the trailers it looks like
it's crazy
I mean what is going on in this movie
but it all looks amazing and I'm really
hoping that the actual story is just as
cool as the visuals are because when you
watch the trailer it blows you away with
the look of the feel of it but you don't
really know much about the story you're
not really told that much even about
what's going on in the film it's just
kind of like these amazing visuals and
I'm hoping since the original director
from the original Mad Max trilogy is
returning with Tom Hardy and I'm hearing
Gibson has like a little cameo that'd be
really cool if he did I don't know it
we'll have to see but I am really
looking forward to seeing Mad Max fury
road I'm hoping it delivers because the
trailer certainly did Tomorrowland is
Brad Birds next film with George Clooney
I'm very intrigued by the trailer I'm
intrigued by the fact that Brad Birds
directing it because the man hasn't made
a bad film yet I'm very excited to see
what he brings to this movie I don't
really know much about it but it
definitely entices me and then there's
this one little independent movie it's
with Dinosaurs and this guy named Chris
Pratt I think and it's called Jurassic
world I hear it's a sequel you know it
could be good I don't know it could be
terrible but you know not a lot of
people are talking about this one and
all right no seriousness I've been
hearing about Jurassic Park for for like
10 years even more than that I think I
mean this movies been in development and
in so many different hands it's cool to
see it finally happening and I'm really
hoping it delivers there's a few movies
on this list that I'm anticipating but
I'm still skeptical about and one of
those is Terminator Genisys I don't
really think this movie looks that great
I think it actually looks kind of
terrible so I don't know but I do want
to see it I want to see what they're
doing and then of course there's Ant Man
which I recently did a trailer review
for not really a mind-blowing trailer
but not a bad trailer looks fun looks
entertaining I'm very curious to see how
the film plays out after the success of
guardians of the galaxy they can
obviously take a very strange story like
a ed more unorthodox comic book story
and make it work and I'm hoping they can
also in the category of anticipating but
skeptical is the Fantastic Four we
haven't seen a single thing about this
movie we just heard a couple story
tidbits and apparently dr. Doom's a
blogger which is terrible in all honesty
that's that's a terrible idea
and there hasn't been a single good
Fantastic Four movie especially not the
one from the 90s nor the two newer one
they all suck so let's see if they can
make a good one I love Miles Taylor
Michael B Jordan is very talented I'm
hoping that it can be good who knows but
I not a single photo trailer nothing
continuing in the category of
anticipated but skeptical the goosebumps
movie why is this on my list because I
grew up reading these books I grew up
watching a television show that's all
for all I know this movie is gonna suck
so hard but I am very curious to see if
it does or if it could be really fun who
knows I had Scott Jack Black in it so
that's a guaranteed good movie not
really but you know whatever still
continuing in the category of
anticipated but skeptical the visit M
night Shyamalan next film now why am I
anticipating this because it was made
for like two hundred thousand dollars
it's a very low-budget independent
thriller financed almost entirely by
Shyamalan which is cool because it's
kind of like he's going back to his
roots it's a thriller that takes place
in this country house and you know I'm
always slightly hopeful when it comes to
him his movies lately have all been
terrible too in all honesty that they've
been terrible like yes he is the
director who initially inspired me to
get into film criticism and into
filmmaking but his movies as of late I
have to admit they're bad they're not
good but I'm really hoping that he can
still pull something good out of them
and it's nice to see him going back to a
non CGI fest a very low-budget thriller
hopefully hopefully hopefully it can be
good but walk directed by Robert
Zemeckis is a film with Joseph
gordon-levitt about a man scaling the
twin towers this is apparently something
that actually happened and this is
something that I'm anticipating because
of the director the trailer looks really
good the poster is also really cool and
there's an untitled Tom Hanks film
coming out this year that's directed by
Steven Spielberg need I say anything
else is there anything else I have to
say no there isn't
I'm hoping it's great odds are it's
gonna be great
anticipated yet skeptical the peanuts
movie I grew up with Snoopy and Charlie
Brown I read the original comic strips I
have some of the original comic strips
that my dad gave me from when he was a
child I grew up with Charlie Brown and
Snoopy show in the 80s I absolutely
adore Charlie Brown and Snoopy and all
that I grew up
that and I'm hoping this movie can be
just as good if not better than those
original TV shows and the comic strip
and if it's made with care and it's
funny then it will be but I'm also
worried because you know it's something
as close to my heart
in Hollywood has a habit of trashing
those things the new Bond film Spectre
I don't have to say anything I mean it's
the next Bond film it's directed by Sam
Mendes once again very rare for a
director from a previous Bond film
nowadays anyway to take over and do it
again I mean Martin Campbell directed -
he did Goldeneye and then Casino Royale
- were the best he launched two bonds
very successfully and originally you
know like back in the 60s with Sean
Connery a lot of the same directors did
it back then but nowadays is more rare
for a director to come on and do another
one so I'm really hoping that Sam Mendes
can knock it out the park again because
I loved Skyfall is a very good Bond
movie and here's a movie that not a lot
of people are talking about the Martian
directed by Ridley Scott starring Matt
Damon is about an astronaut stranded on
Mars that's all I know
but the director and the stars that are
involved with this movie make me excited
about it as well as the plot Ridley
Scott science fictiony space anything
like that yes give it to me Sicario I
may be pronouncing that incorrectly but
this is Denis Villeneuve next film also
with Roger Deakins as cinematographer my
favorite cinematographer so of course
I'm excited to see what that is and I'm
hoping it's great I believe Emily Blunt
is the star which is also an awesome
thing the hateful eight Quentin
Tarantino's next film originally shelved
because the script leaked and now it's
gonna be released they're making it and
yeah Quinn Tarantino it's a Quinton Kerr
movie are you not anticipating it
because you should be mission impossible
5 yes mission impossible 5 they're still
making these because believe it or not
they get better oddly and I think a lot
of that is due to Tom Cruise's idea that
each film needs to have a different
director so the franchise always feels
new and fresh with each one and I'm
really hoping the next one is just as
good as the fourth if not better and
last but not least Star Wars I'm Star
Wars
there's a Star Wars movie coming out
this year guys those are some of my most
anticipated films for this year I'd like
to know what are some of your most
anticipated films for this year there's
gonna be a lot of indie films that I
don't even know about you know like last
year whiplash and Birdman just came out
of nowhere at the beginning of the year
I didn't know what in the world those
were there's gonna be tons of films
towards the end of the year they'll
probably be on my top of the Year list
that I haven't even heard of yet because
you know indie films don't get as much
marketing but as for the films that I
know about that are coming out this year
those are some of the ones I'm most
excited about what are your guys let me
know below and as always thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my next